on friday there was a massive market
sell-off everyone was worried there was
a new variant of covent and literally
the world got lit on
fire everyone running and selling all of
their assets trying to get cash because
there was uncertainty and there was
chaos but maybe actually that was just
an overreaction what we saw was the
stocks coming off of that session on
friday which saw the dow post its worst
day since october of 2020. the dow was
down 905 points for about 2.5
s p 500 tumbled 2.3 and the nasdaq
composite slipped 2.2
all three major index is negative for
the week on based on what happened on
friday now not only were the stocks down
also we saw bitcoin's price draw down as
well and bitcoin's price actually
dropped before we saw stocks drop
bitcoin remains the most honest market
the most free market in all of finance
but before everyone started to freak out
you have to remember two things i saw a
great tweet and i couldn't find it this
morning unfortunately but somebody had
this great tweet where they said on
friday the stock market sold off on
saturday a hundred thousand people
packed into a stadium to watch college
football to watch michigan play so that
tells you that people aren't scared of
the actual variant itself instead what
they're scared of is the government's
response to the variant but what we see
here is bitcoin's price drawdown if you
zoom out and look at this year
over
six times now six different times
bitcoin's price has drawn down at least
20 percent and this is coming from cl
glass node data that was posted on
kryptopia on instagram but what you see
is back in january 29 drawdown in
february 24 drawn on april 26
in may to june 54
drawdown september 37 percent drawdown
and in november only a 21 drawdown now
why is this important one we expect in
bull markets to have multiple 20 to 30
drawdowns happen throughout that time if
you go back to 2017 bitcoin went from a
thousand dollars to 20 000 but there was
at least five i think there were six
different drawdowns of over 20 this is
very natural but what we did see is that
the november drawdown from 69 000 all
the way down to about 53 000 that was
the shallowest the least severe drawdown
just 21.8 percent compared to the other
drawdowns we've seen earlier this year
so before everyone starts to freak out
you have to remember this is part of
what happens in a bull market now that
isn't necessarily going to help the
people who are buying it 65 67 69 000
you have to remember dollar cost
averaging is your friend if you're
willing to buy it at 69 000 of any asset
then if it drops you should be willing
to buy it lower if it goes up should be
willing to buy it there as well dollar
cost averaging is a timeless financial
principle for a reason but not only
should we be looking at the drawdowns
also you can look at here plan b posting
a risk adjusted return chart that shows
all of the various assets now what's so
fascinating about this chart to me is
that when you go ahead and look at this
you can see everything from facebook
amazon apple netflix google tesla also
classic investment assets and then
obviously bitcoin bitcoin remains the
single best risk adjusted return asset
that you can buy and put into a
portfolio when you add in things like
the sharp ratio and you start to look at
the impact that it can have on a
portfolio it becomes a really really
attractive thing that doesn't mean you
should go put 100 of your assets into
bitcoin but what it does mean is if you
have zero percent exposure you're
probably wrong having some exposure
whether it's half a percent or something
more depending on what your financial
goals are is likely to be a good
decision again you've got to understand
what your goals are you've got to
understand what risk you're willing to
take but looking at it from a
risk-adjusted return perspective
bitcoin is very very attractive so when
we see the drawdown first question is
are we surprised that the second people
start talking about a new uh virus
variant that markets sell off like
almost they have uh some sort of like uh
memory of like oh there's a virus
variant assets are going to go down let
me beat everyone to the door and sell my
assets first is that surprising to us
not not necessarily i think i mean it's
people just being scared right and fear
and markets setting in i think it's a
little surprising that maybe bitcoin and
equity markets did it at a similar uh
you know point in time and at a similar
velocity but ultimately this is the same
thing we talk about all the time which
comes to uh how much bitcoin kind of the
volatility of the asset right and when
things are appreciating when things are
going up when we're hitting all-time
highs when we're up gaining 100 200 300
percent during uh kind of different time
periods you look at no one's no one's
saying very much on the bear case right
they're all kind of
everyone's bullish running around saying
great things but then on these slides
people are soon to forget right you said
it earlier we saw 20
25 30 drawdowns three of them previously
oh yeah and then we had a 50 drawdown
right so like these are very very very
common uh for each having cycle and
we've seen them historically but i don't
think that this should be looked at as a
super negative thing right because if
you want to enjoy the upside of that the
volatility provides you also have to be
willing to withstand the downside and
what we've seen over time is that these
happen a lot uh they happen frequently
in kind of these having these four-year
having cycles but also over time that
the appreciation has has greatly uh kind
of benefited from this drawdown right
and what we're seeing now is people that
are willing to hold on to these assets
for a long period of time bitcoin
specifically are greatly rewarded on the
other side of this so i think when you
look at it kind of in the context of
just zooming out and seeing what your
long-term belief is these 20 to 25
percent drawdown shouldn't really be
that surprising and if you really
believe in the asset long term uh you
should just hold on
john what do you think the correlation
is a little surprising to me because
bitcoin i don't think should be
correlated with any shutdown or any
lockdown or anything like that right i
can see how businesses and other equity
companies
are correlated that right they can't
make more revenue people spend less
money all that but traditionally a lot
of bitcoin holders have been holding for
a long time right greater than a year so
i don't think they're really necessarily
moved by that so seeing an eight percent
drawdown one day or 20 in november just
based off kind of new things coming out
in the world and up the possibility of a
shutdown i don't really understand but
you made a good argument when i was
talking to you last night about it was
the fact that people just race to get
liquidity right so it's hey i i just
need emergency money i don't have it
right now all my money's tied up so let
me go ahead and take something off the
top and that's what i could see
happening but like i said traditionally
bitcoin holders are very long term so i
don't think they're really phased by any
news in the market so what you john and
i were talking about last night is
basically this idea of a liquidity
crisis and we did not see a liquidity
crisis on friday right to be clear uh
but there was the uh uh ability to get
there or the early signs of it what
happens in the liquidity crisis is every
asset is denominated in dollars are you
price it in dollars what's bitcoin worth
you say a dollar amount what is real
estate worth you say dollar man what's
that stock worth of dollar amount and so
what happens in the liquidity crisis is
people get very very scared there's a
lot of uncertainty so what they'll end
up going and doing is they'll sell their
assets because they want dollars they
find security in dollars stability in
the dollar for a short period of time it
doesn't matter what inflation is because
it no i know that the dollars one
dollars can be worth one dollar i don't
need to go and try to figure out what
the price is going to be in the future
of this asset so if you go all the way
back to march of 2020 when there was the
government mandated lockdowns and there
was tons of unfi uncertainty and fear
people sold off their assets so you saw
gold go down 15 so equities go down 25
percent saw bitcoin go down 50
and that is because people wanted to
sell their assets and get dollars they
were running into dollars that is called
a liquidity crisis the reason why it's
called a liquidity crisis is because
people are looking for liquidity but
everyone is at the door trying to sell
there's not that many buyers so there's
more sellers than buyers obviously the
prices go down very very quickly that's
what we saw we saw on friday was not
necessarily a full-on liquidity crisis
but there was a kind of a mini one right
is a lot of people wanted to sell very
quickly because of some external factor
and so you get a price drop not nearly
as severe as in march of 2020 but
definitely no noticeable and so when you
start to see this one other thing to
remember is that bitcoin's uh historical
volatility about 12
move in bitcoin is equivalent to about
1.7
move in the s p 500. so every time
bitcoin moves 12 percent it is about the
same as the s p moving 1.7 so if bitcoin
was to go up or down 24
then that is the equivalent of the s p
going up or down about three and a half
percent or so and so they just have a
different level of severity in terms of
that volatility but they still were
acting the exact same if you go back to
march of 2020 all assets sold off it
didn't matter whether it was bitcoin
gold real estate uh stocks cetera
everything sold off because people
wanted dollars it was a liquidity crisis
same thing on fridays people wanted
security they wanted some level of
safety and stability they didn't know
what was going to happen oh there's a
new variant is it real is it bad how
much should we be worried is there going
to be lockdowns travel bans what's gonna
happen to consumer shopping et cetera i
don't know just get dollars and i'll sit
there safely now as over the next 72
hours we've learned more about it and it
seems to not be nearly as bad as people
thought could have happened
people started to go back into the
market we see prices coming back both
bitcoin stocks etc all coming back which
is what you would want to see if you are
a long-term bull